bonjour joueurs l'école est un sujet
assez explosif en france pourtant tu as
deux raisons on a peur de faire du
catéchisme on a peur de faire et ça je
comprends et je n'ai pas la solution clé
en main et je ne pense pas que qu'il
suffise de parler de religion à l'école
pour que tout aille bien
d'autant qu'il ya des questions
profondes de formation des enseignants
de en vain je pense qu'il est assez
nécessaire aujourd'hui de former au
niveau du lycée probablement pas trop
avant les élèves à la pensée religieuse
on a voulu plutôt s'orienter sur les
questions du fait religieux qui renvoie
la religion du côté de du folklore des
fêtes de les traditions qui joue le spar
est important d'être capable aussi de
lire des textes de pensée religieuse
alors ça pourrait se faire dans le cadre
de la philosophie des choses comme ça
mais ça demande évidemment une formation
adéquate des enseignants quand tu peux
pas demander de former sur tous les
sujets sur les sujets sur lesquels ils
sont eux-mêmes formelle
je j'ai pour principe de ne pas
commenter l'actualité donc je pouvais
pas ne pas répondre à cette question
[Musique]
la laïcité qui est le choix de la de la
neutralité des institutions me paraît
alors là pour le coup comme prêtre copte
chrétiens une excellente chose qui n'est
effectivement va partager partout dans
le monde y compris en europe la laïcité
au sens strict il me semble que ça n'est
pas tout à fait la même chose c'est
neutralité des institutions n'est pas la
même chose que la sortie de la religion
de l'espace public nous semble que si
les
les institutions doivent être neutres
dans ce domaine là ça ne nous oblige pas
la société à être neutre dans ce domaine
là et il me semble que en particulier
sur la question de l'enseignement de la
théologie à l'université
la france se singularise on ne lance en
niant quasiment pas sauf à strasbourg et
à metz cause du concordat napoléonien
qui s'applique toujours et cette
exception française me paraît plutôt
contreproductif
[Musique]
alors j'ai juré vous que je me suis posé
des question de quand j'étais plus jeune
de m'investir pour une carrière
politique
ça n'est pas le choix que j'ai fait je
n'ai pas choisi de m'investir en
politique notamment parce que je crois
que la loi est importante pour lutter
contre l'injustice et contre la violence
mais elle ne fait pas tout et que il est
aussi important contre la violence
contre l'injustice de changer le coeur
de chacun un par un et c'est pour ça que
je suis devenu frère prêcheur donc
macron m'appelle pour me nommer ministre
je lui dirai malheureusement je suis
déjà ministres du culte
je suis déjà j'ai déjà une autre
fonction et donc je refuse
[Musique]